wenn du das ganze jahr über aus seinem
garten essen möchtest dann musst du auch
fast das ganze jahr über immer wieder
neue gemüse nachsehen nicht nur im
frühling sondern auch jetzt zum beispiel
im august und viele der gemüse die wir
im frühling ins beet gesät oder
gepflanzt haben sind jetzt auch
abgeerntet so dass immer wieder lücken
entstehen
und wenn du dir jetzt fühlst und der
neue gemüseanbaus dann kannst du viel
mehr aus seinem garten rausholen
das ist übrigens für den boden auch gar
nicht schlimm viele leute denken immer
dass wenn man ein gemüse nach dem
anderen auf einem beet anbaut dass das
dann ausgelost wird und dass das dem
boden nicht gut tut aber schaut euch mal
in der natur und als immer alles
bewachsen und es tut auch unseren bieten
viel besser wenn da immer was drauf
wächst als wenn die nackig da lügen und
wind und regen schutzlos ausgeliefert
sind und ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch
aus sieht aber mein garten ist mir
gerade viel zu nackig und deswegen
schnappen wir uns jetzt unsere
samentütchen und seine ganze bunte
palette von neuem gemüse aus fangen wir
mit den gemüsen an die wir jetzt in
töpfchen sehen also nicht nach draußen
ins bett sondern erstmal in töpfchen die
wir dann entweder im haus vorziehen oder
im gewächshaus haben bis sie dann nach
draußen gepflanzt werden warum ist das
sinnvoll
ich mache das vor allem bei den gemüsen
die irgendwo hinkommen wo jetzt noch
kein platz ist zb im gewächshaus habe
ich jetzt die ganzen tomaten stehen und
die bleiben da auch noch eine ganze
weile und wenn ich da jetzt dazwischen
sachen aussehen würde da ist im moment
überhaupt kein platz für aber wenn die
pflanzen so lange da es noch kein platz
ist in ihren töpfchen warten können dann
sind sie dann wenn die tomaten
rauskommen schon viel größer und dann
kann ich sie direkt dahin pflanzen das
ist also ein vorteil das gilt auch
genauso viel gemüse die jetzt noch im
bett stehen das beet noch blockieren wo
dann aber wieder platz wird und man dann
gemüse nachpflanzen könnte um den platz
besser zu nutzen und dann sehe ich auch
kurven
ja eigentlich immer im haus vor weil der
pflanzabstand bei den super wichtig ist
wenn man die direkt ins beet seht dann
krieg zumindest ich es nicht hin an
korrekten pflanzabstand einzuhalten und
wir starten mit dem spinat den kann man
jetzt auch wunderbar nach draußen sehen
das werde ich euch gleich auch noch
zeigen weil da wo jetzt klappt ist
draußen da werde ich den auf jeden fall
jetzt direkt ins freiland säen
das ist auch immer besser weil die
pflanzen viel besseres wurzelwerk
entwickeln können und viel tiefere
bodenschichten durchdringen und dann
nicht so abhängig davon sind dass man
ständig ist aber der spinat ihr der soll
jetzt zum beispiel später ins hochbeet
wandern und ins gewächshaus und deswegen
musste es erst mal in töpfchen ausharren
bis da überhaupt genug platz ist aber
ich gehe ist es dann immer mit dieser
ball browser an weil die so einen feinen
strahl hat dann verschleppt das allem
nicht die ganzen fallen samen
das ist ganz praktisch da packe ich euch
ab wieder den link in die video
beschreibung und wir machen weiter mit
meinem lieblings salat das ist die sorte
partie eine frostharte sorte ihr kennt
den also auch wunderbar ins freiland
pflanzen wenn ihr den jetzt vorzieht
es ist allerdings ziemlich schwierig
saatgut von dem zu bekommen also wenn
ihr mal welches bekommt dann zuschlagen
und dann die sorte auch immer wieder
jedes jahr im eigenen garten weiter
vermehren weil es nicht garantiert ist
dass man nächstes jahr dann wieder
saatgut von dieser tollen sorte bekommt
das finde ich auch richtig schön wenn
man so eine schöne sorte hat dass man
dann zum beispiel beim saatgut staat
wird mit anderen teilt und andere daran
teilhaben lässt sowieso schöner saatgut
zu tauschen als zu kaufen und in dir
nicht auch dafür euch nicht die erde
jetzt schon mal vorher an
einfach weil das licht kaymer ist und
das finde ich praktischer wenn man die
erde feuer angefeuchtet und dann die
samen nur lose obendrauf aufstellt und
kurz anblickt weil wenn man da noch mal
drüber geht selbst mit seiner feinen
brause
dann schleppt man oft ganz viele samen
in ein kleines tal und
dann gehen die alle auf einem haufen auf
haben nicht so viel platz in ihrem
töpfchen beim salat sehe ich jetzt
erstmal ganz viele samen in eintöpfen
und später wandert dann jedes pflänzchen
in den eigenen topf bis es dann groß
genug ist um raus gepflanzt werden
mangold kann man jetzt auch noch
wunderbar vorziehen
sowohl für das freiland als auch fürs
gewächshaus ist es immer schön wenn man
auch ein gewächshaus im winter dann noch
gut nutzen können weil da kann man so
viel mehr anbauen als draußen und viele
leute nutzen ihr gewächshaus nur im
sommer und das ist total schade also
jetzt ruhig noch ein paar plätzchen
vorziehen im haus damit man die dann
später ins gewächshaus setzen kann
aber wie gesagt der mangold der wächst
auch wunderbar im freiland wenn man dem
jetzt vorzieht und dann direkt ins beet
pflanzt der ist sehr sehr frosthart und
ein tolles gemüse für den späten herbst
und frühwinter hier sehe ich jetzt
gleich so 23 samen in ein loch und die
bleiben dann in ihren töpfchen weil
meiner erfahrung nach das kein problem
ist wenn man zwei drei plätze auf einmal
hat und die dann zusammen stand jetzt
sehe ich ein gemüse aus dass nur fürs
gewächshaus gedacht ist und das ist auch
etwas was ich als einer ausprobiert habe
also da habe ich noch nicht die großen
erfahrungswerte aber letztes jahr hat
das so gut funktioniert da habe ich
blumenkohl und brokkoli ganz spät im
jahr also jetzt so im august ausgesetzt
und dann im herbst ins gewächshaus
gepflanzt und dann konnte ich schon ganz
früh im jahr die erste ernte einfahren
der hat nämlich tolle überwintert obwohl
mein gewächshaus kaputt war im winter
und es da richtig rein gefroren hat hat
er das noch geschafft und dann ganz ganz
früh im jahr wenn man eigentlich fast
nichts aus den daten ernte eine ganz
schöne wundervolle ernte abgegeben das
war ein riesenerfolg deswegen mache ich
das dieses jahr einfach nochmal und teil
das auch mal mit euch damit ihr das auch
mal ausprobieren könnt dann wieder zwei
kandidaten die ihr auch vorziehen könnt
wenn ihr kein gewächshaus für bierkasten
et cetera habt sondern die einfach
direkt ins freiland pflanzen wollt das
ist einmal die rote bete ich bin nicht
so ein riesen freund davon rote beete im
haus vorzuziehen weil das gemüse ist
davon ernten wir so viel und brauchen
auch so viel gerade wenn man das auch
für den winter
lagern möchte dass ich es ein bisschen
albern finde teilweise sich die mühe zu
machen jedes einzelne pflänzchen im haus
vorzuziehen
aber wie so ein toller herbst und winter
ernte ist das eben wunderbar wenn man
die jetzt noch mal schnell vorzieht die
gewachsen sehr sehr schnell die werden
nicht mehr richtig riesig noch vor dem
winter aber immerhin noch so dass es
sich absolut lohnt davon jetzt noch mal
ein paar in die erde zu bringen
und wenn ich meine ins gewächshaus
pflanze dann habe ich da auch auf jeden
fall noch mehr von dann haben die noch
ein bisschen chancen ein bisschen dicker
zu werden
und da sehe ich jetzt die sorte vor uno
aus die haben wir dieses jahr zum ersten
mal ausprobiert und die hat mich sehr
begeistert die macht so sehr dicke
walzenförmigen kugel und dadurch ist ein
jeder pflanze einfach ein bisschen näher
dran wie hier habe ich noch die sorte
robusta das ist meine eigentliche
lieblings sollte davon sehe ich jetzt
auch noch ein paar aus aber für bono ist
auf jeden fall jetzt auch mit im
repertoire
die hat mich sehr begeistert das gleiche
wie bei der roten beete gilt auch für
feldsalat da sehe ich es oft auch nicht
so ein dass ich den jetzt im haus
vorziehen aber jetzt gerade mache ich
doch weit ebenso viele beete noch belegt
sind und ich weiss ich freue mich wenn
ich dann auch eine frühe feldsalat ernte
habe was heißt nur so 12 samen pro
töpfchen und dann reicht es auch aus
machen wir weiter mit den gemüsen die
man jetzt direkt ins beet zählen kann
das ist einmal die karotte da
funktionieren jetzt aber nicht mehr alle
sorten wenn männchen bisschen schneller
sind und manche ein bisschen langsamer
und wenig mehr so viel vom sommer übrig
haben dass die verrotten auch noch groß
werden können
deswegen bei euch ganz gerne jetzt um
die jahreszeit die sorte ganz nah immer
treibt dies sehr frost hat die macht
nicht so große wurzeln also das sind
relativ kleine kurze dinge aber dafür
kann man eben so spät im jahr immer noch
eine tolle ernte einfahren und die
halten sich auch sehr gut im winter im
beet wenn man jetzt
wilm aus problem hat kann man die auch
den ganzen winter über dann immer frisch
aus dem baby an wenn ich sage euch beim
hören einmal frost bekommen haben dann
sind die so süß dass es unvergleichlich
viel besser als jede sommer mittlere
jemals schmecken kann im der nächste
kandidat ist ein besonders hübscher das
ist der pak choi
ich hoffe ihr könnt das sehen wie
wunderschönen er ist ansonsten blende
ich euch auch mal ein paar aufnahmen ein
der ist ein asiatischer kohl schmeckt
sehr mild wächst sehr schnell ist sehr
france hat also ein ganz tolles gemüse
dass ganz viele leute überhaupt nicht
kennen in deutschland dem sehe ich jetzt
direkt ins beet ich habe eben schon
gesagt kohlgemüse sehe ich eigentlich
immer in töpfchen erst mal vor aber beim
faktor ist der pflanzabstand gar nicht
so wichtig also wenn man die ein
bisschen enger macht dann werden die
pflanzen eben bisschen kleiner aber da
finde ich dass der unproblematisch den
direkt ins beet zu sehen
und das hat wie gesagt auch seine
vorteile weil die wurzeln sich besser
ausbreiten können und der pakt sei das
ist auch so ein ähnlicher kandidat auch
ein asiatisches kohlgemüse auch sehr
sehr lecker ein bisschen ähnlicher
wieder china coal und der wandert jetzt
auch bei mir direkt ins beet da ist das
genauso wie mit dem tag soll auch die
beiden baue ich aber auch gerne unter
einem schutznetz an zumindest bis der
erste frost kommt weil die eben auch vom
kohlweißling und den anderen cool
schädlingen heimgesucht werden können
jetzt ist es auch wieder zeit um den
aasee salat aus zu sehen da habe ich
jetzt hier eine bunte mischung mit roten
und grünen blättern auch wieder ein
asiatisches gemüse auch wieder super
forsthart sehr strengen geschmack also
der salat ist richtig scharf
ein kandidat der auch super schnell
wächst ist die herbst trübe
da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche sorten
das hier ist jetzt eine dies pink und
weiß dies auch relativ frosthart und da
kann man innerhalb von kürzester zeit
dass es wirklich ganz erstaunlich auch
rettich feld die auch in diese kategorie
wie schnell man da richtig viel gemüse
noch aus den lücken rausholen kann
die sich gerade in unseren beten auftun
also wenn ihr lust habt auf herbst üben
und die gerne ist dann immer her damit
da kann man auch toll jetzt noch die
kohlen bete ich habe jetzt zum beispiel
ganze weißkohl abgeerntet und da habe
packe ich jetzt noch die herbst rüben
rein dann alle möglichen salate
natürlich am liebsten winter salate die
auf forst hat sind so dass man die
relativ lange dann noch im beet stehen
lassen kann aber eben auch andere sorten
ich habe jetzt hier den little gem ein
meiner lieblings salate aber natürlich
auch den backen kann man jetzt wunderbar
direkt ins beet zählen es ist im august
ja oft relativ trocken mal gucken wie
das dieses jahr sein wird der sommer ist
ja sehr feucht aber normalerweise hat
man es da relativ schwierig dass die
samen aufgehen weil die wie gesagt nur
auf den boden ausgestreut werden und der
boden ja in der hitze relativ schnell
austrocknet da muss man also darauf
achten
manchmal denke ich den noch mit einem
vlies ab und macht das richtig schön
nass damit der boden eben für die paar
tage bis der salat aufgegangen ist
durchgehend feucht bleibt da im zweifel
dann halt drei vier mal am tag mit der
gießkanne drüber gehen damit dass dann
auch klappt oder den salat einfach im
haus vorziehen da hat man mehr kontrolle
darüber wie vor euch der boden ist und
dann klappt das auch dass der aufgeht
muss relativ spät für ist wir haben eben
schon drüber geredet die rote bete die
habe ich ja eben schon in der anzucht
gehabt wenn es euch nichts ausmacht dass
die kugeln im herbst einer relativ klein
sind dann könnt ihr jetzt immer noch
rote beete selm aber wenn ihr den
frühwald kasten habt oder ein
gewächshaus dann ist es praktischer wenn
ihr die da rein seht also im freiland
müsste man ja müsste man schon damit
leben dass die ernte da nicht so oft
wird aber immerhin ich meine wenn die
wenn das spitz uns leer stehen würde
wer soll es nicht aber zum beispiel der
mangold der wird noch richtig groß wenn
man den jetzt auswählt der ist hier das
ist jetzt nicht die leute die die sonst
anbau ihr wisst es ich liebe meinen
bunten mangold aber mein saatgut ist
leider leer
deswegen wird es dieses jahr leider nur
weil es im hang gold geben
naja feldsalat ist jetzt auch im august
fällig damit man den dann im
wintergarten kann auch im september kann
man dann auch immer noch sehen aber da
finde ich es auch wieder schön wenn man
unterschiedliche sätze hat die zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten reich
werden deswegen jetzt auf jeden fall
feldsalat nach draußen ins freiland säen
das ist finde ich
eines der leckersten wintergemüses ist
ein richtiger luxus im winter dann den
eigenen fällt salat zu essen deswegen
nicht vergessen auf jeden fall dran
denken von dann auch den spinat da sehe
ich jetzt frostharte sorten aus ich habe
ja im sommer andere sorten empfohlen die
dann erschoss fest sind hat man dann
immer muss man immer so ein bisschen
variieren was die sorten an geht über
den jahresverlauf und jetzt sehe ich
ganz gern die sorte winter riesen aus
die nennt sich auch verdi ist eine
richtig tolle so hatte der wird bei uns
so üppig und wunderschön das ist eine
richtig tolle sorten empfehlung und wenn
ihr schon pflänzchen vorgezogen habt im
haus die es nach draußen gepflanzt
werden wollen oder ihren auf pflanzen
auf dem wochenmarkt bekommt oder in der
gärtnerei dann gibt es da jetzt auch
noch eine ganze reihe kandidaten die er
jetzt direkt ins beet pflanzen könnt das
ist einmal zb der china coal aus dem
kann man auch sehr sehr leckeren kimchi
darstellen hatte das thema gemüse
fermentieren finde ich total
faszinierend wenn man da so viele
unterschiedliche sachen machen kann um
das gemüse haltbar zu machen auf ganz
leckere art und weise und gibt sie es
wirklich ein sehr sehr leckeres ferment
wenn ihr wollt kann ich dazu auch mal
ein video machen
kohlrabi blumenkohl und brokkoli könnt
ihr jetzt auch noch nach draußen
pflanzen weil die vom herbst noch reif
werden die wachsen relativ schnell für
weißkohl rotkohl und so weiter ist es
jetzt schon relativ spät außer man hat
eine ganz schnell wachsende sorte und
ist dann auch nicht enttäuscht wenn man
im herbst nur ein kleines köpfchen
ernten kann
ansonsten würde ich mich was cool an
geht jetzt erst mal nur auf die drei
kandidaten konzentrieren
dann kann man jetzt auch wenn die
pflanzen habe ich zumindest gehört ich
bin ja absolut kein ventil experte weil
der das das einzige gemüse das bei mir
so gar nicht klappen will aber ich habe
gehört wenn man ihn jetzt pflanzt dann
schießt er nicht mehr und dann hat man
im herbst will ich eine ganz gute ernte
wenn ihr irgendwelche fenchel anbau
tipps habt ich bin sehr dankbar dafür
weil der den ich im frühling gepflanzt
habe der ist super schnell geschossen
das hat mal wieder überhaupt nicht
funktioniert und salat kann man jetzt
auch nach draußen pflanzen egal welche
sorte ruhig einen bunten mix durch einen
anderen pflanzen das ist immer am
schönsten finde ich und wenn ihr lust
habt zu erfahren was ihr jetzt machen
könnt um eure tomatenernte zum
verdreifachen ja kein willst dann schaut
gerne da drüben vorbei ansonsten mache
ich jeden monat hier auf dem kanal
ein außer tipp video wenn ihr keine
außer termine verpassen wollt gerne
abonnieren
und dann geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner wir sehen uns am samstag
um 10 für ein neues video bis dann
tschüss